[Music]
everybody's got their favorite part of
the cycle there are people who love the
wash they love the rinse oh the spin or
the drain i'ma spin guy I love the spin
Derek oh my name is John Charles and I'm
a washer collector enthusiast laundry
day the club that started around 1987 I
think and now we have like 3,000 members
from all over the world we get together
for wash ins you do laundry to like 4:00
in the morning you do your margaritas
your laundry together the laundry
laundry laundry we watch the cycles
you'll see a lot of us just stand there
and watch the whole cycle go through oh
my god everywhere all 3,000 of us come
in with a story like I thought it was
the only one I thought it was the only
person in the world that did this in the
collection I've got 59 machines and I've
got 22 hooked up and running down here
in the basement I have a good
representation of everything that was
made from 1938 to today
and I take them all apart and I restore
them because I want to know everything
works inside the machine and then the
laundry is for me it's sort of like the
frosting on the cake these machines
represent a lot of ways of doing things
in each decade that changed that we no
longer do and I think it's something
that should be preserved for other
people if we can get them interested I
just can't go to a cocktail party say
how does your washer doing they look at
me like I was crazy but I can get
together with these guys let my hair
down it's just so much fun to be able to
have a conversation about it because I
know laundry is a chore for everybody
else but for us it's it's play
I don't think there is a contradiction
between a simple life and a spicy food
perhaps someone who's living a simple
life needs to have something to spice it
up maybe that works
my name is father Richard walls and I am
a monk of Subiaco abbey which is a
monastery and Subiaco Arkansas after I
graduated from high school I entered
monastery so I've been 55 years a monk
monk sauce which we produce here at
Subiaco abbey is an Abba narrow pepper
sauce we call that monk sauce because
it's monk made anybody who has handled
oven or peppers knows that you should
not be doing this without a glove on a
good month is a good balance between
prayer and work
it ought to be done find out if it's any
good where's the water
I suspect a lot of people have kind of
fanciful ideas about monks and what they
do and they get into the monastery and
they find out that monks are very much
like everybody else I feel very close
connection to the land in this area the
longer that I was here the more I
realized that God got me here because he
knew how to be in a community the
community is a very important thing to
me until about 1902 legal food
preservatives included chemicals like
formaldehyde borax and copper sulfate
that is until one guy organized a poison
supper club to stop it and became the
father of the FDA mm-hmm okay
here's the story in order to keep food
looking fresh food manufacturers used a
slew of chemicals copper sulfate a
common pesticide made canned peas bright
green borax and formaldehyde were packed
with meat to make it appear fresher at
this time in our history there were no
true food regulations you didn't need to
label your ingredients there was no
safety testing no monitoring thank you
dr. Harvey W Wylie a chemist with the
crazy idea that these chemicals had no
place in our food he started some
hygienic lab trials where he could
officially test the effects of these
poisons on the body it was easy to get
the chemicals but he needed the bodies
and that's where the poison squad came
in
the first 12 members of the poison squad
were volunteers from the Department of
Agriculture and they volunteered to eat
his poison food for six months so he
could track the effects it had on them
each day the menus would change and
Wiley's volunteers never knew which
poison they were consuming a dinner at
the poisoned supper club might look like
this applesauce soup turkey can string
the sweet potatoes white potatoes beet
red and butter coffee rice pudding and a
little board
throughout the trials Wiley noted signs
of acute poisoning including upset
stomachs nausea diarrhea vomiting kidney
damage you know things that happen when
you get poisoned and this did not stay
hidden the press caught on and in 1906
the first food regulations were passed
this ultimately led to the creation of
the FDA so thanks dr. Wiley our food is
so much better without all that borax
[Music]
the first time I ever made a delivery
was in the spring of 1953 and I was six
months old on my father's route
I grew up doing this Elson man my name
is Walter Beckerman and I am a seltzer
man ourselves a man is the order taker
the bottle fixer the driver to deliverer
the salesman your everything rolled into
one if people ask you what it is about
the Celtic business that that makes you
want to continue doing it
you hold that cells about and you hold
history your whole memories you hold an
object of beauty
that's 1871 it still works without these
bottles this business doesn't exist this
machine is a Barnett and foster siphon
filling machine I think it was made in
London early 1900s it's a six siphon
wave filling machine goes round through
the carousel and only one bottle goes in
at a time so it's a lot of work the
reason this is a better Seltzer is
because there's nothing else in this
seltzer other than New York City tap
water which is triple filtered through
sand charcoal and paper and co2 and
fortunately as long as the machine is
fixed and I have a place to fill I can't
see any reason why this business should
be a nail in the coffin situation where
it's over it won't be over to the last
bottle Celsius squirted and I don't see
that anytime soon you're playing with
and against all the different people in
the club and you learn to appreciate
them because of that it's just a little
family it's an odd little sport and it's
unique it's easy to play but hard to
master
[Music]
that one short oh three the Cadieux cafe
is the only place where there's
authentic Belgian feather bowling in the
United States it's a bowling game that
uses wooden disks that you throw at a
feather at the opposite end of the
length trying to get close to the
feather it's similar to bocce or
horseshoes and then it's a target sport
that way the unique thing about this one
is that the lane is convex and the ball
tends to move in odd directions you can
score points by being the closest with
your color ball closest to the feather
of the same color yellow touching yellow
some people are really good right away
other people when they're going to club
for a while and I still don't know what
they're going to do out there when they
throw the ball oh it was a point it
wasn't Cadieux cafe today is is a bar in
a restaurant in Detroit this
neighborhood was a largely Belgian
American neighborhood at one point when
the club started in 1933 this is a place
for recent immigrants after the war to
come over and have a little taste of
home
more popular that's been them in our
average attendance for bowling every
week has gone up
three four years it is a good group of
guys here you know they're through all
of all walks of life
you sit there with every week with them
you bowl with them Ebola gets them and
it's just a good time
[Music]